okay I'm here with Ali why is that your
real name
no actually Wow yeah sure
way too deep I know my row name's Oliver
white oh well so Ollie wait is your real
name what do you think it was gonna be
like Frank Jones or something I know I
don't know if you're some like American
from Maine that is moved to London and
tried to make the most British name
possible yeah oh why it's just my stage
name like
what ice cream is the most racist mint
oh why because it's green because it's
green and it's what's your favorite ice
cream mints
if you were trapped in an elevator with
a complete stranger how long could you
hold your piss do I have a lack of water
bottle or anything to put it no wow you
left it at your desk
hallo mind the lift for it could be days
right I would try to prise open the left
it may maybe make a hole you absolutely
cannot get out of Bonaparte do it I'm
and it's one other person who's not
gonna die in the next couple of days I
will live to tell this story to someone
else I'm gonna have to politely say I'm
really sorry I need to go to the toilet
I'm gonna piss in my shoe or in the
corner
I think the shoe is like the most
logical play like if you don't want it
to go everywhere
do it in a shoe it contains the liquids
this is spoken from a man that was
clearly pistol I just came into my head
I was like shoo it's the most container
like object exactly
if you could only eat one thing for a
year what would it be
it'd probably be yogurts even though I'm
allergic to them like I live and thrive
off your boots
wait but say this word again yogurt how
do you say it say it one more time
yogurt did you call it yogurt well how
do you say yogurt that's yogurt yogurt
what is your favorite animal and would
you eat it well that question took a
turn I think one of my favorite I don't
I really I really like pandas look very
cool all like koala bears I've never
I've never seen any of them though
obviously seen them on the internet but
I've never actually like Oh have you
never seen a video of a koala bear
making noise I've heard the sneezing
panda sneezing panda adorable koala
making noise Oh awful really
like that's what a qualify Oh awful hey
hey everyone loves slots for some reason
gross gross have like some proportion to
your body their head is too small for
the full size Observatory gentle cream
no they're calculating and just
judgmental like said judging you the
whole time they're moving yes but it
became like quirky and fun to be like I
love sloths yeah I think I was kind of a
trend or something it's like kind of one
direction
everyone loves one direction were you
just talking to someone in the cab
something god I was just addressing
everyone that's one direct that must
have looked quite weird yeah ands like
oh this is his clan message to the rest
of the clan I guess
okay Olli welcome to your challenge I
mean out of the way you all but yeah
okay hey Olli you've heard the chicken
nugget challenge right yeah today we're
playing the blindfolded chicken bucket
challenge think about it okay so in
front of you on the floor I don't have
you can feel it nope I just kicked a
bunch wait where you've stolen my bucket
no I'm okay so we eats now that okay
this is not gonna go out hit in the room
are six rubber chickens so we have to
blindfolded Lee find three of said six
rubber chickens place them back in our
bucket you can't hold your bucket husky
back on the floor and the first person
to three rubber chickens wins or so okay
okay we'll be careful
great advice thanks guys okay so place
your bucket down and also it has to be
in your bucket and not my bucket okay
okay I have to get my chicken so it's
the first of three rubber chickens wins
are you ready I'll eat any fun I'm so
not ready okay
on your mark get set go Oh No wait what
is this why is this I've got one
I'm Genova did you win
oh can you idiot that's it what is this
thing okay what oh Jesus no that's what
that's the baby ah yes
no no no that stuff you know they make a
squeak Did you touch my butt you say
where you are so I don't come with my
son I've sincerely lost my entire okay
that's a winner I'm going to you aside
please one way careful I'm on the floor
I'm completely turned around I just need
you okay jack very laughs he's over
there don't touch me I hate music
where's the chicken there's a bucket
over here right
there's a kid's a bucket before another
just ran into the camera and I think so
but I thought the book it was over here
James where's my bucket so we've spent
more time than we should blindfolded
looking for chickens and things have not
developed as planned so now we'll be
getting some help from some friends to
help us locate the chickens in the room
we're gonna get hot and cold symbols
signs language etc to find out where the
chickens are okay we trip one and we
have to collect two more to be the
winner and go
where do it coming open now yeah
wow that seemed a lot bigger than I
thought it was I feel like you know if
you have any like consciousness as a
child coming out of a womb I feel like I
just came out of a woman I'm sweaty I'm
covered in gross stuff and there's
chickens in my bucket but the thing is I
one just I think you kicked my bucket a
couple of times yeah yeah I think we
both admit that we both cheated I didn't
cheat at all
well you kicked my bucket I moved your
bucket right the way over there and I
stole a chicken
okay so let's admit that Ollie cheated
only is great disagree that with equally
agree that London's oven mitts are weird
no we have separate oven mitts like
gloves yeah yeah yeah make sure that you
go over and listen to the full podcast
interview with Ally on iTunes look for
not too deep with grace Helbig and go
subscribe to Ally white TV here on
YouTube super fun time I'll have you
feel any better about yourself dude I
feel we're like best friends now aren't
we
I'm gonna go take a shower would you
like to have two penises for one day I
think it would be very interesting
depends where the second one goes yeah